une femme à la tête des scout et guides
deur clair Verdier bonsoir une femme et
en plus elle est linoise d'abord j'ai
envie de dire vous êtes la première
femme à présider ce mouvement c'est vrai
oui c'est c'est la première fois
effectivement et pourquoi pas avant vous
savez pourquoi c'est le hasard je ne
sais pas je pense que c'est le hasard on
a au sein des scout d'Europe une à la
fois effectivement deux deux branches
une branche masculine et une branche
féminine
et à chaque échelon il y a un
responsable masculin et et féminin et on
peut grimper toute la hiérarchie comme
ça et puis quand on arrive au Président
il y en a il y a plus qu'un nom et cette
année effectivement ils ont choisi une
femme on l'impression que vous vous
posez quand même une une pierre dans
l'histoire du mouvement non vous le
vivez comme quoi comme une une
reconnaissance du chemin parcouru une
vraie fierté un vrai honneur en fait
c'est ou avec plus plus encore
d'humilité en fait je suis quoi j'ose
j'ose penser qu' en fait c'est plus mes
compétences que mon côté féminin qui qui
l'a emporté euh mais je reconnais que
c'est un vra un vrai honneur et de
pouvoir servir un mouvement comme
celui-là donc je suis très touchée et
puis je pense que eu égard aux réactions
que j'ai eu au moment de au moment de
mon élection qu'est-ce que vous ont dit
justement les hommes du mouvement alors
c'est pas c'est pas vraiment les hommes
qui m'ont parlé ce sont les femmes qui
sont venus me remercier et qui se sont
un petit peu reconnus alors que vraiment
la parité est parfaite chez nous donc
est parfaite pas au sommeil voilà mais
oui par plus alors vous n'êtes élu que
pour un an malgré tout est-ce que vous
allez révolutionner le le mouvement des
scout et guides d'Europe non il y a pas
de révolution en vue loin de là parce
qu' on travaille vraiment dans la
continuité de ce qui était fait par les
présidents précédents et par le Bureau
précédent donc on va poursuivre sur les
chantiers qu'on avait entamés entre
autres on voudrait vraiment valoriser
tout ce que font nos chefs et vraiment
les mettre en valeur leur les remercier
parce que c'est vraiment eux qui qui
font vivre le mouvement c'est pas nous
on on assure le le cadre on fait en
sorte que présidente quand même vous
être Président je suis présidente mais V
je sais que ça va pas être facile
peut-être de se dire ça est je suis
présidente mais vous êtes la ok je suis
présidente mais vraiment merci au chef
merci merci et vraiment on fera on fera
tout pour que cette expérience que vous
vivez que vous faites vivre aux jeunes
elle soit reconnue et reconnue par le
par le monde de l'entreprise par le par
les autorités civiles on va s'arrêter un
instant sur votre parcours au sein du
mouvement des guides scoup vous avez
commencé vous aviez 13 ans oui j'ai
commencé comme j'éta jeunes guide
effectivement donc j'ai et j'ai
poursuivi
ça le le scotisme m'a accompagné pendant
toutes mes études à l' SCP m'acompagné
pendant ma courte vie professionnelle
par que ah oui j'aiai pas dit alors on
allit en parler mais alors vous avez
j'ai découvert ça en disant V biographie
vous avez été trader vous avez fait une
école de commerce et vous avez été
trader pendant 4 ans effectivement j'ai
fait l'école supérieure de commerce de
Paris et à l'issue effectivement j'ai
j'ai été trader pendant 4 ans ça a été
enthousiasment et puis je me suis mariée
et j'ai avec mon mari nous avons eu 10
enfants donc là euh j'ai fait un choixre
de famille nombreuses et euh voilà j'ai
j'ai eu la chance de pouvoir choisir de
de estce est-ce que les valeurs du
scouotisme aident dans la vie
professionnelle en tout cas vous ont
aidé dans la vie euh universitaire et
puis dans la vie professionnelle même si
votre vie professionnelle a été courte
entre guillemets mais est-ce que vous
avez l'impression que ça peut aider
certaines valeurs peuvent aider ben je
pense que à la fois euh ce sens de la
débrouillardise ce sens du concret euh
la franchise ça bah ça effectivement ça
facilite la la vie professionnelle dire
que ça fait le tout je ça serait mentir
sinon on ferait pas des études mais euh
effectivement ça ça rend service cette
capacité à vivre en à vivre en équipe
fait que effectivement le travail en
équipe vous semble plus facile et
accessible euh pourquoi vous avez choisi
les guides et scout d'Europe parce qu'il
y a aussi les guides et scout de France
vous auriez pu choisir l'autre mouvement
euh comment en fait il y a expque-nous
peê peut-être la différence entre les y
a il y a essentiellement deux grandes
différences entre le mouvement des
guides et scout d'Europe et le mouvement
des scout et Guides de France en fait
nous sommes un M un mouvement non mixte
donc en fait moi c'est c'est un choix
volontaire effectivement de pouvoir
permettre aux jeunes bah justement
d'avoir une totale liberté surtout à
l'âge de l'adolescence ou le regard de
l'autre porte pose porte tellement de
conséquences donc il y a cette non
mixité et puis la la la fidélité aux
intuitions de Baden Poel qui entre
autres sur la tranche d'âge 12 17 ans
euh mettez bien en valeur cette ce ce ce
système des patrouilles c'est c'est des
patrouille ça fait un peu sourire parce
que ça ça fait pas trouille les castor
mais en fait c'est ce ce groupe d'amis
euh ils sont ils sont huit maximum ils
sont menés par un plus grand qui a qui a
4 5 ans de plus que le plus jeune et qui
qui est chargé de le faire grandir et
vraiment c'est l'éducation du jeunne par
le jeune sans sans rupture entre 12 et
17 ans d'accord ça c'est ce qui vous a
convaincu oui en alors hasard du
calendrier vous allez dire c'est hasard
du calendrier enfin quand même malgré
tout il y a une femme qui a été élue
présidente ENF à la tête des SC et guide
de France c'est une femme aussi elle
s'appelle Catherine larieux est-ce que
vous la connaissez alors ce jour je ne
la connais pas
puisque mes responsabilités actuelles
était très limité certes à la plus
grande province de France au sein des
GUID scout d'OPE qui est la province des
ilines mais je crois que Catherine
larieux n'est pas yvinoise donc je n'ai
pas eu l'occasion de est-ce qu'il y a
des liens entre votre mouvement GUID
d'urope et les GUID de France voyez le
le 19 juin prochain effectivement je
rencontre le président des SC GUID de
France la présidente non non je
par une structure qui est un petit peu
différ un président et une délégé
général général un mot quand même sur le
mouvement des GUID des scout de France
c'est le deuxème mouvement en France SC
d'urope pardon c'est le deuxè mouvement
en France avec 30000 adhérents avec
30000 effectivement 30000 adhérents 5000
jeunes bénévoles et environ 300000
anciens ça veut dire qu'il y a 300000
jeunes et moins jeunes qui sont passés
par le mouvement euh quelles valeurs
sont véhiculées hein vous avez parlé de
la responsabilisation il y a d'autres
valeurs qui sont aussi prenaient la
place de la religion mais en fait il y a
les il y a cinq cinq piliers sur lequels
sont assises entre guillemets toutes les
activités de nosf de nos chefs qui sont
effectivement le sens de Dieu le sens de
l'autre par le service le sens du
concret donc cet attachement réel euh le
développement de la santé et puis la
formation du caractère voilà donc ça ça
ça irrigue toutes les activités et et
quand vous dites la formation du
caractère c'est-à-dire bah la formation
du caractère fait que la volonté la le
désir d'aller jusqu'au bout de ne pas se
laisser accablés par les éléments je le
weekend dernier un certain nombre de
scout guide étaient en weekend parce que
ils sont partis à 2h de l'aprè-midi il
fais un temps radieux et se sont pris
l'orage du siècle le le soir alors
effectivement quand onne pas et surtout
on réfléchit à deux fois en faisant son
sac et en pensant à sa et à sa cap de
PLU ah oui voilà donc on est prêt le
scootisme ça se vit en famille chez vous
vousavez dit vous êtes mère d'une
famille nombreuse est-ce que tous vos
enfants sont scout de même alors tous
mes enfants sont o où ont été scout
parce qu' entraîné à 25 ans elle est en
étude de médecine donc là elle a elle a
effectivement arrêté depuis un an depuis
depuis un an et puis et puis j'en ai non
mais sinon tout le monde effectivement
cotise au mouvement des gu SC d'Europe
d'accord j'avais une question quand même
sur votre uniforme ça ça qu'on dit je me
trompe pas sur les les je sais pas les
petites blasons que vous avez sur le
côté ou je sais pas comment vous appelez
c'est les flots les ça oui tout à fait
oui expliqueznous ça alors en fait ces
trois flots qui rappellent et qui
FL qui rappelleent effectivement que
j'ai pris un un engagement un engagement
de guideîné qui est un petit peu la en
quelque sorte la synthèse de toute une
vise scout le jaune c'est la couleur des
des louvetau des louvettes donc cette
âge 8 12 ans c'est la couleur de la de
la joie de la foi le vert c'est la
couleur de du des 12 17 ans c'est
l'espérance et le rouge c'est la couleur
effectivement des aînés c'est la charité
et le service aux autres d'accord et
c'est pour ça que ça explique que vous
ayez le foulard rouge aussi et le
foulard rouge effectivement c'est ce
foulard des aînés qui qui ont choisi de
Rs rester en service rester en service
c'est le le maître mot ou en tout cas le
ma oui c'est un peu c'est le maître mot
oui c'est le maître M quel est le
prochain moment important pour les
Scouts d'Europe alors à l'échelon des
ivelines il y a toujours il y a notre
pédrinage de rentrée début octobre en
fait on il y a 5500 scoutter guides sur
les yvdines donc habituellement nous
allions jusqu'à chartre et là nous
sommes trop nombreux pour chartre donc
nous aurons deux route une qui marchera
jus vers Manthes et l'autre vers vers
chartre donc ça c'est pour les pour les
ivelines et au niveau national et
international en fait il y a un grand
rassemblement du 1er au 11 août prochain
en donc 2014 un un euro Jam qui qui va
réunir 10000 scoot et GUID dont 2000
français
donc au niveau des evelines par exemple
il y aura 4 à 5 compagnies sur les 35
qui pourront qui pourront participer
donc il va y avoir une année de
sélection gentille et donc la la branche
la section scout par exemple fait un
énorme rally de province donc réuni
c'est un méga un méga weekend avec un
méga grand jeu le weekend du 11 novembre
le département des ivines par rapport à
d'autres départements est assez fort
pour le le scootisme notamment les scout
d'Europe c'est un département assez
porteur ou bah c'est en fait c'est c'est
assez amusant parce que le département
des divvines constitue à part entière
une province au niveau des des GUID des
scout d'Europe puisque c'est 20 % des
effectifs d'accord ah oui oui
donc ailleurs une province regroupe en
général trois ou quatre départements
mais nous on a la la chance parce que
parce que les familles nous font
confiance parce que les familles sont
nombreuses effectivement de constituer
une seule une province sur un
département d'accord ben écoutez voilà
on a appris des choses merci cl Verdier
d'être venu sur le plateau et donc
félicitations pour votre vre élection de
de de présidente des scout et GUID j'ai
l'imion que vous réalisez pas encore ben
en fait ça date il y a pas très très
longtemps quand même mais mais
effectimement non non mais je j'assume
j' j'en suis très fier très bien merci
beaucoup merci beaucoup claire Verdier